♪ (classique) ♪
- Quel son magnifique! Alexandre
Da Costa, c'est un stradivarius
qui vaut entre 5 et 20 millions
de dollars. C'est beaucoup
d'argent, mais est-ce que
ça vaut le coup?
ALEXANDRE DA COSTA, violoniste
- Moi, je trouve que ça vaut
le coup bien sûr comme musicien.
C'est un instrument qui a vécu
des siècles, de l'histoire. Là,
il est dans mes mains, je peux
partager vraiment la musique
qui sort de cet objet absolument
fabuleux avec tout le public.
Donc je suis très, très heureux,
et puis oui, moi, je trouve
que ça vaut la peine.
- Vous n'êtes pas trop nerveux
de le laisser comme ça,
un tel instrument?
- Bien, c'est sûr qu'il fait
partie de ma vie quotidienne,
donc je vis avec l'instrument
de manière naturelle, mais
j'ai toujours le coin de l'oeil
qui vérifie.
- On peut le laisser
sur le piano?
- Je pense que oui.
- Bon. Alexandre Da Costa,
vous allez bientôt avoir 40 ans,
mais vous avez commencé à jouer
très jeune. Premier concert
à l'âge de 9 ans, protégé de
Charles Dutoit, et aujourd'hui,
vous êtes une rockstar dans le
monde de la musique classique.
À quoi ressemble votre quotidien
dans le monde de la musique?
- Bien, c'est assez occupé,
ça, c'est sûr. Et je pense que
c'est là où je me sens le mieux,
lorsque j'ai beaucoup de projets
en même temps qui roulent, là,
je sens que je peux vraiment
m'épanouir.
♪ (classique) ♪
Mais j'ai toutes ces tournées-
là, donc je suis constamment
dans un avion. Là, je reviens
de trois semaines et demie
en Amérique du Sud, à Bogotá.
Je m'en vais dans quelques jours
après toutes les premières
qui se passent en ce moment,
je m'en vais pour l'Espagne.
Ensuite, les États-Unis.
Je m'en vais en Australie
ensuite, je reviens pour
quatre jours ici, je repars pour
l'Australie. C'est un petit peu
fou! Vie de famille aussi, c'est
parfois difficile, ou déchirant
plutôt d'avoir à partir et
laisser mon fils et ma femme
un peu seuls derrière, donc ça,
c'est le revers de la médaille.
Mais je dois avouer que lorsque
je suis en tournée et que
je peux donner mon 100 %,
et puis je suis sur scène,
je vis vraiment, c'est sûr.
- Vous êtes un musicien
classique, mais sur votre
27e album solo, vous versez
dans le classique rock.
♪ (classique rock) ♪
Avez-vous vendu votre âme
au diable?
- Tout à fait!
(rires)
Ça, ça se fait il y a
très longtemps, et ça, ce n'est
que le résultat ou le coming-out
plus ou moins de mon processus
artistique et créatif.
- On vous voit sur une moto
avec du cuir!
- Oui, c'est ma moto et
ce sont mes vêtements. Donc...
- Mais c'est vraiment vous, ça?
- Pas de mensonge ici. Oui, oui,
c'est ça.
- Mais on est loin de
l'Orchestre symphonique de
Montréal, là, avec les costumes
et tout.
- Oui, mais justement,
cet album-là se veut...
Je suis affranchi sur cet album.
J'ai décidé de proposer quelque
chose qui soit complètement
libre.
♪ (classique rock) ♪
Même si dans mon milieu
classique, c'est moins bien vu,
si on peut dire, pendant de très
longues années, je dois dire
aussi que je me suis plié à
l'image que la musique classique
impose à ses membres, si on peut
dire. Aujourd'hui, j'ai décidé
que j'allais faire un disque qui
me fait plaisir. Il va y avoir
certainement des commentaires
qui soient positifs ou négatifs,
ou contre ou pour, mais ce n'est
pas vraiment important parce
que ce qui est important, c'est
la créativité. L'album, il est
ce qu'il est. Ça a pris deux ans
pour moi à le faire. Donc j'y ai
pensé longtemps, ce n'est pas
un coup de tête, je n'ai pas
voulu faire un acte de
rébellion. J'ai voulu faire
quelque chose qui me plaise.
souffrir un peu pour l'art.
Parce que c'est physique ce que
je fais. Je l'ai toujours dit,
je suis un ouvrier de
la musique, moi, je joue de
la musique. Je ne suis pas...
Je suis en partie peut-être
un intellectuel, mais en partie
beaucoup moindre que celui
d'être un gars manuel. Donc pour
moi, c'est important de savoir
que mes muscles sont au service
de ma musique. Puis non,
ce n'est pas vraiment un travail
parce que le seul travail que
je vois dans ma vie, c'est
celui de prendre un avion,
donc de faire l'activité d'aller
à un aéroport, de laisser
ma famille derrière pour aller
faire qu'est-ce que j'aime et
qu'est-ce qui est ma passion.
Ça, c'est la partie travail.
Mais aller sur scène, répéter,
parler de projets.
Je veux dire, il n'y a pas
de samedi, il n'y a pas
de dimanche! C'est une passion,
ça fait partie de ma vie.
Si on arrête ça, bien là,
je ne vis plus.
- Alexandre Da Costa,
merci 1000 fois.
- Merci beaucoup.
- N'oubliez pas votre violon!
- Je ne l'oublierai pas.